hello everybody my name is Ryan Johnson
and I'm a data science adviser here at
posit and welcome to this month's
Enterprise Community Meetup where we'll
discuss another endtoend data science
workflow using Posite team and just as a
reminder this is a recurring event that
occurs on the last Wednesday of every
month and we hope it'll serve as a good
primer for those that are brand new to
posit team but also help current posit
team users become more familiar with our
tools
now with the holiday season upon us
there's no better way to express your
holiday spirit than by sharing the gift
of a beautifully crafted organized data
science workflow so with that in mind
and during today's demo we're going to
discuss tools and techniques within
Pit's tool chain specifically designed
for sharing and collaborating with
others so to kick things off I first
want to make sure everyone here has a
solid highlevel understanding of posit
team
so posit team it's a bundled offering of
our three professional tools we have
posit workbench posit connect and posit
package manager and if we start right up
here at the top with your data
scientists they're going to be creating
insights so writing code within posit
workbench and they can choose whichever
IDE they want it can be our studio
Jupiter lab jupyter notebook or vs code
and they can also program in whatever
language they want so if you're are
developers maybe they're creating things
like shiny applications or our markdown
or Cordo documents and for your python
developers maybe they're creating
Jupiter notebooks or fast API streamlet
shiny V and the list goes on but it
doesn't do your developers any good if
they can't share this content with the
people that need to see it and that's
the whole purpose of posit connect this
is our professional publishing platform
so it gives a home for all this content
your data scientists are creating so
that they can easily share them with the
people that need to see them and that
could be you know co-workers it could be
decision makers at your company or maybe
you just want to share it with friends
and family and then our last tool is
posit package manager which does exactly
as this name implies it helps control
all those amazing opsource R and python
packages your team uses it also gives a
home to any internally developed R and
python packages we also just released um
some really cool new features within
package manager so you can actually
control access over which packages your
team can use now before we get into the
actual demo I want to take a moment to
talk about you know why does posit care
so much about open-source data science
in the list I'm going to present it's
not an exhaustive list but I did want to
highlight a few points why posit is so
invested in open source data science
especially in the context of sharing and
collaborating First open- Source data
science is free meaning if you want to
share your workflow with someone else
there is no requirement to purchase any
software all the components needed to
run the workflow are completely free of
charge Second open- Source data science
it promotes transparency now when you
share a workflow with someone they will
know everything and I mean everything
that went into your analyses because
they have access to your source code
there's no proprietary or blackbox
analyses that are hidden from your
collaborators
and finally open- Source data science
allows teams to easily collaborate with
specific people but also with the
greater data science Community I'm sure
many folks listening to this webinar
right now have likely had a data science
question and posted it to a public forum
and hopefully got a response from the
community this is the type of data
science learning and support that posit
wants to
encourage so what options exist today to
collaborate and share content using
posits tools tools well the first way is
to share your source code and that's
where Version Control comes into play so
many of the tools that we create here at
posit including the various idees
included in posit workbench they have
Integrations to make working with
Version Control including get AB Breeze
Version Control and repository hosting
services like GitHub or maybe your team
uses bit bucket are some of the most
important tools for data science
collaboration
we also have some cool features built
into Posite team that can assist with
data science collaboration including
project sharing and get back deployment
so project sharing this is a feature in
posit workbench and allows for users to
work together on our Studio Projects you
can even do Live code editing with this
feature which we'll demonstrate a little
bit later on finally we'll finish our
workflow today by demonstrating get back
deployment within posit connect which
can be used to directly deploy content
to posit connect from a git
repository so to go over today's
workflow we are first going to start by
creating a new repository on GitHub
which will be the home base so to speak
for our collaborative data science
project we'll then pull the repository
into pait workbench as an R Studio
project for this simple workflow we're
going to be creating a shiny application
in R and we'll show you how more than
one user can collect collaborate on the
same piece of code using Version Control
as well as project sharing and I'll be
showing Version Control features in both
our studio as well as Visual Studio code
running within posit
workbench finally we'll show you how to
publish the collaborative shiny
application hosted on GitHub to posit
Connect using getback
deployment so to kick off this workflow
here I am within my GitHub homepage and
I'm going to start a brand new
repository so in the top right corner
you'll see this green new button go
ahead and click on
this I'm going to choose me as the owner
and I'm just going to give this
repository a random name I'll just call
it test repo
123 for the description I'll just say
this is a test repo we'll make this
public and I'll go ahead and add a read
me and then I'll hit create
repository so here's the current state
of repository it's pretty Bare Bones the
only thing you'll see inside of it is
that read me file and that's pretty much
it but what I want to do next is I'm
going to take this repository I just
created and I'm going to pull it into
dep pait workbench as an R Studio
project and to do that the first thing I
need to do is just grab the URL for this
GitHub
repository so let me navigate over to
posit workbench and if this is the first
time you're seeing posit workbench this
is the home screen when you first log in
and I'm signed in in this evalue uh
instance as publisher one and I'm just
going to open up a brand new session by
clicking right here you can see the four
separate idees that posit workbench
currently supports and for right now
we're just going to live within our
Studio Pro and I'll go ahead and kick on
the
session so here we are within the r
Studio IDE on the left hand side we have
our console in the top right corner we
have our environment Paine and in the
bottom right corner you can see our file
directory so I'm going to go ahead and
pull in that GitHub repository as an R
Studio project and to do that there's
actually a few different ways you can
create a project in our studio but my
preference is to go in the top right
corner you can see project none I'm
going to click on this and select new
project and when you click on that
option you'll get this popup menu to
select how you want to create your
project you can create a new directory
which is like creating a new file on
your desktop or your computer for
example you can also create a project in
an existing directory if that file
already exists on your computer or you
can pull in a project from Version
Control and this is the option I want to
use since we're using git in GitHub I'm
going to select git and then I'll paste
in the URL for my
repository we'll just leave the name as
test repo 123 and I'm going to place it
in my home directory of my project which
is represent presented by this
Tilla and then I'm going to use R
version
4.3.2 for this analysis and just a cool
feature a posit workbench is you can
actually choose from different R
versions and you can have as many R and
python versions as you want installed on
your server and with that we'll hit
create
project every time you create a new
project it'll always open up a new R
studio session so here we are and if you
look in the top right corner you can see
now we're in the test repo one two 3
project so now that we have this project
created we first want to create
something because right now it's just a
Bare Bones project and so I'm going to
create a shiny
application now within the r Studio IDE
there's actually one that comes built
into the r Studio IDE so if you click in
the top left corner up here you'll see
Shiny web app so I'm going to use this
as kind of like a scaffolding but I'm
actually going to bring in a custom
application that our team has created
so I'm going to call this test app and
I'll just leave it as that test app this
is going to be a single file app. R and
I'm going to place it within our
projects directory which again we called
test repo 123 and I'll hit
create you'll notice down here in the
file directory and I can make my screen
a little bit bigger here in my file
directory right here you can see test
app that's the directory we just created
and inside of it is this single file the
app. r file which is what you're seeing
now in the top left corner of the r
Studio IDE this is your Source pane now
if you're not familiar with shiny shiny
is just a way for you to create
interactive web applications using rcode
you can also do it in python as well now
I mentioned before that this is like a
placeholder application um that you can
run by clicking this little run
application button and you can see
here's an example shiny application but
let's go ahead I'm going to pop in some
code for a little bit more of an
interesting shiny application so I'm
going to go ahead and delete all this
placeholder information and I'm going to
copy in some code over here on my screen
and I'm going to past it
in all right so this is a slightly
longer application but it's still not
too long it's less than 100 lines of
code but it's going to incorporate some
really cool new features of shiny that
we're really excited about including
this BS lib package which is really
great for creating really nice looking
shiny applications and dashboards so
let's go ahead and run this application
and explore it a little
bit so you can actually see right here
I'm actually missing a package this is
actually a pretty cool little tangent we
can go on here so I need to actually
install this icon for this application
to work so when I click install I'm
going to go ahead and hit this install
button we're going to get this jobs tab
that opens up and it's going to go
really fast I'm actually using posit
package manager to install this package
as a pre-built binary so it's only going
to take a couple seconds and boom it's
done so now we can try running the
application and here we
go all right so here's this shiny
application again using BS lib and what
it's looking at is a data set called
Palmer penguins and some of you may have
heard of this data set before it's a
really popular uh data set for just
doing you know exploratory data analysis
but it's actually real data which is why
I like it so much and you can see we get
some nice value cards along the top that
summarizes some information about these
various penguins and then you can see
some charts in here like the bill length
Bill depth Bill Mass separated by either
species island or if it's a male or
female penguin just some cool features
of BS lib we can click on these
individual cards and expand them so you
can see the plot in more detail so this
is going to be the shiny application
that we're going to work on
today all right so the first feature
that I want to go over within posits
tools for sharing and collaborating is
going to be project sharing let's say
for example that you want to call up
your coworker or someone on the other
side of the world and you want to have
them help you out when writing this
shiny
application now if anyone here is
familiar with like Google docs for
example and you know when two people are
working on the same Google doc at the
exact same time you can actually see
their cursor and you can see them type
in live and that's a lot of the same
functionality that you'll get with
project sharing within posit workbench
and these R Studio Projects so I'm going
to go ahead and share this project this
test repo 123 project with another user
on this instance of posit workbench so
I'm first going to click the name of the
project in the top right corner and
you're going to see this option to share
project so in this popup window we can
choose who we want to share this project
with so I mentioned before that on this
instance I'm currently uh logged in as
publisher one let's go ahead and share
it with Publisher 2 so I'll start typing
out publisher 2 and this is typically
going to be tied into your
authentication within your team so I'll
select publisher 2 and select add and
there we go we've now just shared this
project with Publisher
2 so now we kind of have to use our
imagination a little bit and I'm going
to switch roles into to publisher to and
so I'm going to bring on another screen
here and I'm going to use the kind of
the dark format of pic workbench because
I'm here logged in as publisher to and
here on the home screen of posit
workbench you can see over here on the
right hand side there's the test repo
123 and you'll see the little folder
icon with the arrow inside of it that
indicates a project that has been shared
with me as publisher to and I can click
right here to jump right into that
project all right so here I am within
that project test repo 123 and the first
thing you'll notice up here in the top
is this little p that stands for
publisher one so if I want to follow
publisher one's cursor all I need to do
is click on this box right here and you
can see it opens up this icon or the
window right here with the shiny
application that we were working on
previously and then if I switch back
over to publisher one you can see that
little p up here that up here that
stands for publisher 2 and let's go
ahead and follow their cursor as
well so now I'm going to try my best to
demonstrate this functionality so here
in the background we have publisher one
and in the foreground we have publisher
two and if I start typing here you'll
notice I'll just make some comments here
that this edit was made by publisher 2
and then if I wanted to conversely I can
come back here you know make another
edit as publisher one and you can see
how that's been reflected right here uh
in the other window so again this is a
great option for live collaboration so
there's a piece of source code that you
want to work on at the exact same time
with somebody else then you should
really check out um project sharing from
within posit
workbench now while project sharing is
an extremely powerful tool we'd
certainly advocate for the use of versin
control and repository hosting services
like GitHub bitbucket G lab for your
sharing of data science projects so what
I'm going to do now within this session
again here logged in as publisher one
I'm going to take all this source code
that we've been working on including the
shiny application I'm going to save it
here locally within posit workbench and
show you how we can push these changes
up to that GitHub rep repository that we
previously connected to so the first
thing I'm going to do is save this shiny
application you can see here it's in
this red text with a little asteris that
lets me know that's not currently saved
so I'm going to go ahead and hit the
floppy dis uh symbol right here it's
going to save my file and now to show
some of the git Integrations if you look
over here in the top right hand side
there's a tab up here in the top right
called git and this is going to show you
all the git Integrations within the r
student Studio
IDE and currently we see a lot of
question marks right now so the first
file is this get ignore file this was
actually added by our studio when we
created this project as well as this
test repo1 123. rrage file which is
always created in the home directory of
a project in R Studio project and then
we also have this test app directory so
I come back to my projects directory
which is right here and inside of it is
going to be that sh
application now currently we see all
these question marks and that's because
Git Version Control it sees these files
but it doesn't really know what to do
with them like should it ignore them
should it track them but we want to go
ahead and have get track these files so
that we can push them up to GitHub so to
kick off that process the first thing
we're going to do is stage all these
files and I like to think of it just
like staging for a play so the curtains
are still closed you want to make sure
everything things set up in the right
place it's staged and ready to go for
when those curtains open so let's go
ahead and Stage these three objects so
I'll click the bottom one the middle one
and the top one right
here so once we have these all staged
we're going to go ahead and make a local
commit to Version Control and if you see
right here this toolbar it provides a
lot of helpful um operations for git
right here within the r Studio IDE so
you don't necessarily have to use the
terminal or the command line so I'm
going to select this commit box and it's
going to open up a window here which I'm
going to
adjust and let's just go ahead and
explore this for a second so over here
in the top left corner this is the same
window that we were seeing within the r
Studio IDE the three files and now since
they're staged you can see this little a
that corresponds to being added so these
have been added to Version Control
they're staged they're ready to go and
down here at the bottom you can see any
differences now every single one of
these files is completely new to Virgin
control which is why everything's
showing up in green but if you were to
make any edits or remove any lines you
might see some red lines in here as well
corresponding to things that were
deleted so if you're happy with all
these changes which we are we have this
new shiny application that we worked on
collaboratively with Publisher 2 let's
go ahead and Commit This locally to
Version Control we have to add a commit
message here now this is a a bit of an
art form because you want to make these
commit messages as informative as
possible but also pretty short so I'm
just going to say create shiny app and
that's pretty much it I'll hit
commit you'll see this popup window
which shows you some of the git commands
that were run in the background along
with its output so if I close this
window you can now see the git window
over here is now empty but we see this
little kind of information uh flag
letting us know that our branch is ahead
of origin main by one commit and what
that is basically telling us is that our
GitHub repository hosted up in GitHub we
are actually one commit ahead of what's
on GitHub so if we're ready to push
these changes up to our GitHub
repository we can again use the r Studio
IDE to help us out here by simply
clicking this push
button now you may have to set up your
git and GitHub credentials beforehand
this is something I did before this
Workshop just to make sure that my
instance of our studio here can talk to
GitHub and that it knows who I am and I
have the credentials to make these
pushes so now that we pushed those
changes let me switch back over to my
GitHub repository and Let me refresh my
page and so here's the current state of
our GitHub repository we have that
readme file which we originally created
here's that rrage and get ignore files
that our studio automatically added for
us and here's our test app here's that
shiny application where we're working on
I can click into it click on the app. r
file and see all the
code so now that we have the shiny
application on GitHub it is primed for
collaboration so let's say for example
that publisher 2 wanted to pull in this
GitHub repository and do some changes to
their shiny application which we're
going to demonstrate right now so here's
the current state again of our GitHub
repository let me go ahead and regrab
the URL and then I'm going to drag in
Publisher
2 I'll try to make my screen a little
bit nicer to see here all
right so I'm going to make some changes
to that shiny application as publisher
to again because again I'm a
collaborator I want to work alongside
publisher one to develop this shiny
application now we could do this in our
studio but let me just go ahead and show
you how someone might do it within
Visual Studio code running within posit
workbench so I'm going to open up
another session because you can have
multiple sessions running within posit
workbench and I'm going to select Visual
Studio code and hit start
session all right so here we are within
Visual Studio code and it's pretty much
a blank environment if I click on my
file explorer over here it's letting me
know no folder has been opened and if we
look along the left hand side you'll
notice there's actually a source control
icon so we can click on this and let's
go ahead and clone in that repository
that I just copied the URL for so I'll
click clone repository and paste in the
URL and I'm going to place it right here
in my home
directory let's go ahead and open it
up and now you can see within that test
repo 1 two 3 and here's my test app with
that app. R file being shown right here
and again this is all running within vs
code so let's say again as publisher 2 I
want to make some changes I'm not going
to make any dramatic changes here I'm
just going to scroll down to let's see
here line 29 you can see here's the
title of this dashboard Penguins
dashboard let's make that a little bit
more informative let's say Palmer
Penguins dashboard because that's the um
the data set that we're going to be
using so we're just going to add polymer
here I'll hit save
and you'll notice there's this little
one icon over here in the source control
so let's go ahead and click on that and
you'll notice that there's been a change
here within this app. R file so let's go
through some of the same steps we just
did within our studio so the first thing
we need to do is we want to Stage this
change and we can do that by clicking
this little plus
icon and once it's been staged we want
to add a commit message and I'm just
going to make it nice short and sweet so
say change app title and we'll hit
commit and once those changes have been
committed again locally here within vs
code running on posit workbench we can
then push those changes up to GitHub so
again we can just click on the sync
changes and that should push everything
up to our GitHub
repository all right so now with that's
done let me switch back over to my
GitHub
repository and I'll refresh my
page let's just go into application and
make sure that change is there so we'll
scroll down here and now you can see on
line 29 Palmer Penguins
dashboard now I'm going to switch back
over to publisher one here because again
now I have a change in my GitHub
repository that's not currently
reflected within my local code here as
publisher one you can still see title is
the old just Penguins dashboard so now
would be a great great time to pull in
those changes from that GitHub
repository those changes made by
publisher too and they do that again
within the r Studio IDE we have nice
easy features to do this we already
pushed before let's go ahead and
pull and once we do that you can see all
the output here from running the poll
command and now if we scroll down in our
source code
here polymer has been added to the title
so again that's how you can work
collaboratively uh with version control
using whatever IDs you want with
whomever you
want okay so we've shown you a few
different things now which are helpful
for collaborating and sharing data
science workflows with others but now we
have this great shiny application over
here on the Le hand side that's been
worked on by two separate developers and
ultimately we want to be able to share
this application with whoever needs to
see it and that's where posit connect
comes into play so we're going to go
ahead and show you how to publish this
application to pait
connect now here within the r Studio IDE
you can actually Implement something
known as push button deployment and we
showed this in some of our previous
workflows here's that little blue icon
in the top of your screen which you can
easily push and I could manually publish
this tup posit connect and this is a
great option especially if you just want
to uh quickly share an application with
somebody or any piece of content content
that can be hosted on
connect however if I publish this to
connect and then I come back to my
source code and I make a change I'm
going to have to click the button again
and republish so it's a bit of a manual
process so what we're going to show you
here is something called get back
deployment so instead of publishing it
directly from the r Studio IDE we're
actually just going to have posit
connect look at our GitHub repository
and if it ever detects a change in that
GitHub repository so a commit in that
GitHub repository it can automatically
rebuild that content for
us so to kick off the get back
deployment process we have a few things
we need to do to get started so I'm
going to go ahead and just clear my
console down here in the bottom left and
I want to go into the directory that
houses the content that we ultimately
want to be published on connect so here
within that test app directory you can
see we just have the single app. R file
and I'm actually going to set this as my
working directory just to make things a
little bit
simpler now when we publish this
application to posit connect posit
connect needs to know some information
about my current working environment
such as what packages am I using what
versions of those packages what R
version am I using so that information
is needed by connect so that it can um
you know just make sure it runs this
application correctly without any issues
now for push button deployment this
little blue button a lot of that's done
automatically but if we're going to use
get back deployment we just need to
provide that information and it's super
easy to do it so from within the
directory of the content you want to
publish all you need to do is run from
the RS connect package there's a
function called Write manifest that's it
I'll hit enter it's going to capture
some of my dependencies using another
really great package called rnv and then
it generates this manifest.json file
I can click into it we can just take a
quick peek and it's pretty noisy there's
a lot of great information in here that
connect can easily read but for the most
part it's just information about
packages in my environment and like what
versions of those packages and where I
obtain them from all the information
connect needs to replicate my
environment exactly as it is right here
with imp posit
workbench so now that we've created this
file we want to make sure that we also
include this file within our GitHub
repository so let's go ahead and just
show you that workflow one more time so
we have this manifest.json file that's
been added uh within my git repository
or within Version Control let's go ahead
and Stage it I'm going to commit
it and we'll just make a quick message
here of add manifest file and then we'll
commit that up to
GitHub so if I come back to my GitHub
repository we click on test app I need
to refresh here oh see I've done
something wrong here oh yeah I gota
gotta push it obviously so let's go
ahead and push that there we go so I
committed it and then I had to push it
now if I refresh my page we have the app
and we have the Manifest file right
along side of
it so let's go ahead and take this
application on my GitHub repository and
publish it directly from this GitHub
repository so I'm going to regrab the
URL for the third time and I'm going to
switch over to posit connect here in
this demo environment so this is the
home screen of posit connect just some
example content that we have here just
to explore all the various pieces of
content you can currently host on posit
connect but in the very top here you'll
see this publish but dropdown and I'm
going to select import from git I'm
going to paste in the URL and I'll click
next and it's going to ask me what
branch I want to publish from now our
GitHub reposit itory just has a single
Branch it's that main branch but it's
actually a pretty cool workflow here
where you can have multiple versions of
a single piece of content published on
different branches so maybe you have
like a production version on the main
branch but maybe you have a development
version on some other Branch you can
actually publish two pieces of content
from the same GitHub repository from
different branches but we just have one
branch that's main so we's look
next and then it's going to look for
directories where you can find that
manifest.json file so these are
Deployable directories and it found one
inside that test app directory and all
we have to do is give our application a
name I'll say test app we'll just keep
it nice and simple and then we'll hit
deploy
content so at this point posit connect
is Reading in that manifest file and
just making sure it can replicate my
environment and once it's done we can
click open content and we'll just give
it a few seconds to boot
up all right so here's that shiny
application that we've been working on
and you can actually see the title here
reflects that change that publisher 2
made polymer and it looks and it behaves
just like it did when it was running
within posit
workbench now to demonstrate how
powerful get back deployment is so this
app application is now linked to that
GitHub repository and if anyone anyone
I'm collaborating with makes a change to
the main branch on that GitHub
repository it'll automatically be
reflected here within deployed content
on posit connect so it'll automatically
stay updated so let me actually go ahead
and show you that worklow
quick I'm going to come back here to my
environment publisher one but anyone can
do this publisher to or anyone else
that's working on this GitHub repository
and has access to that main branch let's
go ahead and make another change to the
title so I have Palmer Penguins
dashboard and I'm just going to add a
dash no this is I'm going to add a
smiley face there we go kind of silly
but another change we'll hit save now
you can see in the git tab we have a
modified this file so let's go ahead and
Stage it I'm going to commit it locally
and I'll say add smiley face to
title and then we'll Commit This locally
and then push it up to
GitHub so now if I switch back over to
my GitHub repository let's just check
the application and make sure that
change is
reflected all right so you can see the
smiley face right here on line 29 now
I'm going to switch back over to pait
connect I'm going to refresh my page
here and you'll notice that the smiley
face isn't yet there that's because this
piece of content usually by default it's
only going to check every like 15
minutes to see if there's a change to
that g over repository so we could just
hang out here for 15 minutes and wait
for that change to uh uh take effect and
this is a a time frame that can be
modified by your system administrators
but we can actually just manually kick
off that check so if I go to my info tab
here scroll down check for updates from
periodically for that gith repository or
I can just have it manually check and
click update now so let's go ahead and
click this
button so it see says changes were found
in the get repository so it
automatically rebuilds it hit
okay and now you can see the smiley face
reflected here in our final shiny
application so again get back deployment
is a fantastic way for uh collaborating
with others and also having a piece of
content hosted on connect that's
automatically updated anytime makes
someone makes a change to that branch on
the GitHub
repository
and that wraps up our last Posite team
workflow of 2023 and I really hope you
all found today's session helpful for
collaborative data science now usually
for these sessions we'd have a Live
question and answer right afterwards but
just given the time of the year and the
fact that a lot of people are out of the
office we instead wanted to provide you
with another way to ask questions so on
the screen here will be a link to a
forum on Pit's Community page which we'd
welcome any questions about today's
content finally as a reminder all of
these posit team demos are recorded and
publicly available which you can view on
YouTube we hope you have a great holiday
season and we look forward to seeing you
again for our next workflow in